all right the good guys are still on the
quest to destroy the ring and evils on a
quest to destroy good guys so hey we got
the two towers the Lord of the Rings the
two towers warning this time as before
this is going to be completely spoiler
filled so I'm you've been warned there's
no other way to talk about Lord of the
Rings then to just spoiler it out so as
we saw at the end of the Fellowship of
the Ring the Fellowship is completely
split off Boromir died Frodo was like
I'm going to Mordor alone and then
Samwise Gamgee is like I'm going with
you so the two of them went off to do
that merry and pippin the two other
hobbits were captured by yokai which are
pretty much orcs on steroids and Aragorn
Legolas and Gimli are like we're not
going to abandon them to get tortured
deaths so we're going to go get our two
Hobbit friends back so they're going
after merry and pippin now we enter the
two towers and this movie starts out
awesome it's just going over the
mountains and you hear gandalf throwing
down with the Balrog and it goes into
the mountain and it shows him toe-to-toe
with the Balrog and he's like you shall
not pass BAM
then the Balrog Falls he whips Gandalf's
leg and then he falls he's like I lose
then when he falls the camera goes down
with him and shows what he did
he's the biggest badass in Lord of the
Rings history Gandalf is fighting the
Balrog he's grabs him by the collarbone
he's taking his sword and just beating
the out of him digging his sword in
tombs sparks and fire flying out of the
Balrog that rocks smacking him around
gandalf just grab onto his horn the
entire way down the mountain you're like
this is insane the two towers is a great
movie it really is but for my money it's
the sweetest scene in the entire movie
at the very beginning the two towers
more or less concentrates on the world
of mankind and Rohan Rohan or Rohan
however you want to say it has king fade
and King fading is like a good guy but
he's being controlled by Saruman I
touched on Saruman a bit because I
haven't touched on him yet and he's
really important and you kind of have to
talk about him he was the white wizard
you know the head of Gandalf's order but
he threw in his lot with Sauron now
saurons using him to make a big Ruka
army to wipe out the world of man
because sauron's learned rumors that it
maybe is sealed or Zaire is coming back
that ain't good not for him so yeah just
wipe out every human being that lives
you'll eventually kill Aragorn that's
pretty much the plan however one thing
Saruman did not count on is that there
will be another white
it will be Gandalf the White yeah
Gandalf the white now he was king
awesome badass before when he was the
gray now he's the white evil has no shot
they showed that in the trailer I
thought that was a weird thing I'm like
why would you show that there are a lot
of people out there that don't know that
Gandalf is going to come back as Gandalf
the white or Saruman as he should be
however you want to see it so it's the
same earth theater he's just all he
looks all crippled and gross and old and
Gandalf pretty much performs an exorcism
with his staff against him and Sarma's
like if I go they Odin dies and Gandalf
overpowers him and I love that scene for
two reasons one Saruman learned that
there is another white wizard and it is
Gandalf in which he is in trouble and
two he's in trouble because Gandalf
overpowered Saruman for the first time
like ever
yeah Saruman learned a little bit of
news of that day that just it wasn't it
wasn't good news not for him jumping
over here we have Frodo and Sam's pretty
much you know the entire point of this
entire story Frodo is still going to
Mordor to drop the ring into the volcano
to take out mr. evil only thing is he
doesn't really know the way he and Sam
are going in circles the ring is really
becoming a burden to Frodo you really
see the gravity the situation weighing
on Frodo in which case Samwise Gamgee
you see his role in this whole thing
Samwise Gamgee is Frodo's motivation you
really see that in the two towers it
culminates in Return of the King but
this is the first time you're like oh I
get it
Samwise is actually badass awesome but
you see the scene stealer in the entire
movie and that is Gollum Andy Serkis as
Gollum was like it was one of those
roles where you're like this is one of
the most memorable performances ever
Gollum is a really wretched little
creature you've probably seen Gollum by
now he had the ring for five hundred
years and he really wasn't much
different from a hobbit when he first
got it the ring is so evil and so
corrupting Gollum is the end result of
this so you kind of look at ghullam
you're like yeah Freddy she'd really
make haste with the process or else
you're gonna be like Gollum Gollum just
such a tormented creature you're like he
can tell he kind of wants to be good but
the dude has like multiple personalities
so he has this other voice in his head
there's a scene where he's talking to
himself and he's like not master los
precios first masters my friends I don't
have any friends never the lot you're
just like
that guy's got issues he really does
have issues too but I love damaged
characters like that Gollum is pretty
much the epitome of damaged character
Gollum was pretty much the character
where people were like yeah the Academy
needs to think about whether or not they
should give an actor who did motion
capture for a character and Oscar cuz
Andy Serkis deserved it and I'm just
saying and upon all this Frodo and Sam
run across far amir now far mirrors
actually boromir's brother and you don't
see this in the initial theatrical
release you're just like a farmer feels
like he has something to prove but why
you learn in Return of the King why but
in this special extended edition of two
towers you see why cuz his dad said so
in the scene in the two towers when he's
like no we're taking the ring to Gondor
you understand why you just feel the
weight on his shoulders Bruce like cuz
my dad's a douche chef there's one thing
that slows the movie down a bit for me
it's actually the whole merry and pippin
in the end thing that tree beards an nth
and so pretty much like walking trees
but their tree herders and he walks
really slow with really long strides and
he talks really slow which makes the
scenes feel slow I'm no tree I am and
then he talks a lot and he talks about
stories you really you're supposed to
feel this way because you're supposed to
feel how merry and pippin feel which is
like dude we're hanging out with this
really old guy who tells stories that we
don't care about and it's really putting
us to sleep however you kind of feel
that way too so you're like let's let's
speed these things up please get back to
the hole rohan thing and helms deep and
Frodo and Sam and Gollum Gollum Gollum
would be great the show more golems
golems awesome now again I love
Treebeard I love merry and pippin and it
doesn't detract from the movie as a
whole in fact at the end when they see
Isengard in their life now we're gonna
beat the piss out of Isengard cuz
Saruman to douche and these throw rocks
and they unleash the river you're like
okay this is awesome
leading up to it was a bit like okay
filler time let's just get back to the
other stuff then you get to the Battle
of Helm's Deep all these human beings
are bottle necked into this little
stronghold like we're totally going to
hold those 10,000 Eric I come tromping
up and they're like yeah I don't think
you're going to in fact I'll bet you a
dollar
they don't really bet a dollar they just
start beating the out of the place
and the battle is awesome and it's
intense and it's it's the climax of the
movie see the Lord of the Rings the two
towers is that middle
mark Fellowship of the Ring it was
really cool seeing this fellowship the
introduction to the characters in the
world who just didn't offer the entire
thing so the two towers you're familiar
with the characters so now they're just
in a dire dire dire situation and it's
really great and really cool however
that's the immortal battle is ooh which
one's better Fellowship of the Ring or
two towers for me I like Fellowship of
the Ring more than two towers I can
watch Fellowship of the Ring every day
two towers is a great chapter to the
Lord of the Rings trilogy they take the
dialogue and characters a little further
they actually is funnier than Fellowship
of the Ring also the dialogue between
Gimli and Legolas has more humor to it
movie itself has more humor in it I
suppose you need that otherwise you'll
be like wow from the Shire to this this
is almost culture shock things are just
going very badly for the good guys
however although I love fellowship with
a ring a little more than two towers the
Lord of the Rings trilogy as a whole
remains the pinnacle of epic there
personally growing the interaction
between the characters is bigger it's
growing also the friendship between
Legolas and Gimli that's growing and
it's a dwarf in an elf that shouldn't
happen not in this world
Samwise Gamgee finds his role with Frodo
Frodo she's being burdened by this ring
and Gollum is the scene stealer a couple
seems that slow down with the walking
tree doesn't change the fact that the
two towers is still completely epic and
badass and the Lord of the Rings the two
towers is awesome tacular
or so the Lord of the Rings the two
towers what did you think of it what did
you think of it compared to the
Fellowship of the Ring whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more